objectif est une démilitarisation et
dénazification pour que en grand jamais
c'est la société ne se produise
nous avons vu des tentatives des
tentatives de s'emparer des
territoires eurus
concernant effectivement elle est
question de l'intégrité territoriale et
la souveraineté de l'ukraine
je tiens à attirer votre attention
sur la déclaration de 1970 ce qui porte
sur et les relations amicales entre les
pays conformément aux à la charte de
l'onu ce document qui a été approuvée à
l'assemblée générale mentionne que le
principe du respect de l'intégrité de
l'intégrité territoriale
et doivent être en conformité avec le
droit de l'eau de détermination et par
conséquent tu et les
états
doivent
reconnaître ce droit le régime qui vient
de des nazis n'a pas eu l'intention de
reconnaître ce droit nous avons constaté
un nombre croissant et des
violations des droits de l'homme des
centaines des milliers de personnes qui
ont ce faire en libye en irak a et ans
l'ex yougoslavie
tout cela at il montré un coeur
il y à une opposition à la fédération de
russie
on peut effectivement violé tous les
droits de l'homme
soit disant et tout cela est permis
si effectivement on est soumis à
l'occident soit disant civilisé
il a été même a décidé par l'union
européenne
d'approvisionner l'ukraine en
armes létales et pour nous il était
extrêmement important de préserver de la
vie la vie humaine
nous n'avons aucune intention
de limiter les droits des ukrainiens
parce que nous avons les mêmes ma
culture traditions nous avons les liens
de sang des millions d'ukrainiens vivent
aujourd'hui en russie nous vous avons
été ensemble depuis des années et nous
serions ensemble
voyons c'est que
sylvia en cap 20 qui est un string pour
transformer le pays
différemment donc et l'hystérie que nous
avons à
l'occident souvent que les états unis et
tous les alliés
soaring qu'on serait la russie
j'espère également que lors des
pourparlers qui se dérouleront entre la
russie et l'ukraine
l'ukraine qu'on prendra toutes ses
responsabilités
et
sera capable 2
d'accepter les conditions qui vont pas
reprendre les accords de minsk pour
terminer je tiens à souligner
il est
l'importance
de ne pas
refaire la déclaration qui a été adoptée
en 1940 subsistent et ne pas remettre en
question le consensus qui a été posée à
ce moment là
le conseil des droits de l'homme et aux
nations unies est a appelé g1 pour ne
pas utiliser les doubles standards pour
ne pas interférer dans les intérêts des
autres c'est là le seul moyen d'assurer
les justice pour pouvoir a assuré
également et respecter les droits de
l'automne dernier n'est sûr
mais un pays qui renouvelle le
néonazisme et qui se tiennent là les usa
sanctions économiques qui sont tournés
conçoit les civils
fait ce sont des tentatives de
compromettre les domaines sportifs et de
l'éducation de l'information qui
compromettent tous les contacts de ma
vie l'occident
ruine à tous les instituts qu'il a
également construit ensemble y compris l
a1 sculpture prêter l'institut de la
propriété bien la philosophie
occidentale
une telle philosophie occidentale qui
doivent être arrêtés
nous pensons que le principe de
l'université de luminy réalité dans la
charte des nations unies
la lumière cité des les droits doit
s'appliquer à tout le monde